as simple as that sounds the way you put
it how come
how come there is 70 million americans
that disagree with you how come
how maybe it's not disagree with you why
is it so hard to get the other 70
million to see the data and say that
makes sense rather than saying let's
just raise the taxes on everybody
i don't know i mean maybe it's much
easier to be an accountant than it is to
be an economist
you would think if you raise taxes on
the rich if they don't change their
behavior they'll pay more and they'll
they're so rich they can afford it well
i have a story to tell if
you if you have a minute go for it i i
will tell you my
make-believe story of robin hood uh that
i introduced economics but it takes
about three minutes or four minutes
you know robin would wake up in the
morning and you know this is uh your mom
telling you the story robin has stole
from the rich and he gave to the poor
he made the poor better off he was the
hero made the rich worse off but they
could afford it you remember the story
of course
well the story starts off with robin
hood and nottingham he and his
get banned to marry men they don their
light green leisure suits you know the
curly toed shoes the
hats with the feather in them and they
they go running out to the trans forest
throughway
and when a richie would come by i mean a
really rich this guy didn't have a
silver spoon in his mouth
this guy had a golden goblet in his
throat all right right there
they would jump out of the bushes on him
they'd steal everything the guy had
they'd let him run naked out of the
forest back to his castle
but don't worry uh that guy has so much
left at the castle he can afford it here
do that if a guy came through the forest
was doing really well but not a
super richie they'd take a large chunk
of what he had but not all of it
if a normal everyday average merchant
came through the forest they just take a
token from that guy
in this in the vernacular of the modern
day society patrick
they had a progressive stealing
structure from the merchants when they
came to the forest
you with me at the end of the day robin
hood and his
band of merry men would go running back
into nadia and they'd wander the streets
of nottingham if they found some guy who
was down out some guy with nothing i
mean just nothing
they'd give him a whole pile of goodies
if they found an ordinary sort of
working poor guy
they give them a smaller bundle of
goodies you know the more you make the
less they give you the less you make the
more they give you
if you found a normal everyday average
citizen walking along the streets and
nottingham
what they do is say hi my name is robin
hood i want to tell you i'm the local
redistribution station around here i
just want you to know we love you
here's five bucks take the wife out to
dinner have a good time it's on me
and by the way if they bumped into
someone rich and nodding him they just
might steal from him too
okay now that's the story
now let me just imagine bring economics
back into your life all right
this is going to now become instead of a
moral story an economic story
imagine you were a merchant back in the
ancient days of nottingham
how long would it take you to learn not
to go through the forest
one trip maybe one trip that's all those
merchants
those merchants who were really rich
with the golden goblets in the throat
needed for armed guards to take them to
the forest now we call those armed
guards today
lawyers accountants deferred income
special lobbyists favor grabbers
all of that stuff but they were really
held expensive back then as they are now
the merchants who couldn't have formed
the armed guards they'd go around the
forest not the route around the forest
to trade
was full of rocks bumps logs holes etc
it cost them a lot more to trade with
the neighboring villages
it increased the cost of trade
dramatically both the armed guards and
the
circuitous routes around there so they
had to sell their products at higher
prices at the end of the day
robin who had no contraband whatsoever
because all the guys were so heavily
armed he couldn't rip him off
he went back into nottingham with
nothing in his hands to give the poor
the disenfranchised at all
and they had to face much higher prices
by stealing from the rich
robin literally made the poor worse off
and that is the true story of
redistribution
and that is what exactly happens in this
society today
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you